in Ohio a grand jury has voted not to
charge eight police officers who shot
and killed a 25 year old black man as he
ran away from them last year that man
Jalen Walker was killed after a traffic
stop and a car chase where police say he
fired at least one shot from his vehicle
the chase ended on foot with officers
firing 94 shots and hitting Walker 46
times he was unarmed in the chase but a
gun was found in his vehicle Lilia
Luciano has reaction now to the Grand
jury's decision and we remind you that
the video of this incident can be
difficult to watch
the grand jury concluded that the
officers would legally justified in
their use of force the decision not to
pursue criminal charges against the
eight officers who killed Jalen Walker
came nearly 10 months after they shot
the 25 year old just after midnight on
June 27th investigators say officers
spotted him driving with a tail light
out and a broken light on his rear
license plate choosing not to follow him
until they saw him drive through the
same intersection 10 minutes later
police say Walker fired a shot from his
car as officers pursued him
and that at the time they believed he
was still armed when he fled his car he
was not together the officers shotted
him nearly 100 times over seven seconds
an autopsy showed Walker was hit 46
times the officers involved in the
shooting will remain on administrative
duties for the foreseeable future
following the grand jury vote Akron
leadership urged protesters to
demonstrate peacefully
what surprised you the most about this
outcome
how one-sided the presentation was how
police friendly it was that was shocking
attorney Bobby deccello is representing
Walker's family he said they plan to
file a civil lawsuit against the city by
the one year anniversary of Walker's
death we are looking forward to a Time
where I can be in court and I can
question the officers and I can present
evidence and challenge for the first
time what these officers
say happened and why they say they did
what they did for CBS mornings I'm Lilia
Luciano